Hello world it Saroj and I'm going to talk about a topic I very rarely talk
about.
It's called East sports.
So e-sports refers to any kind of online gaming related to tournaments and
players earning rewards.
It could also be related to fantasy football,
fantasy basketball or even real life sports.
But the idea is that you consider a game where with other players as a kind of
sport and there was some reward involved.
And specifically I'm talking about this because there is this great intersection
between cryptocurrency and East sports.
So I'm going to talk about four different tokens in this space that are
intersecting these two spaces very well.
And in along the way I'm going to explain how proof of stake works.
So it's really hard to find any kind of readable proof of state code,
but this is a great way to do it because one of these coins actually uses proof
of stake.
And I'm going to use that as a segway to talk about proof of stake.
Also,
I'm going to talk about how token sales work because two of these coins do that
really well and very easily.
So if you want to make your own coin related to East sports or gaming or any of
the above,
then you're,
it's,
it's easier for you to do so.
So this market is growing very,
very fast.
If we look at the data,
the revenue from east sports by the way,
is that it's really a,
a newer thing.
East sports and the revenue from east sports is growing at a staggering rate
every single year.
If we,
if we look at this graph right here,
right in the past five years even,
it's gone from 0.5 to 1.5 on this,
see agr scale and the audience is growing as well.
So millennials,
my generation and even the generation that's younger,
loves east sports.
So just going to grow over time.
The core audience,
the data shows globally is 85% male.
Okay?
So it's between 16 and 36 year old males,
uh,
that and they have an average household income of about 75,000 US dollars.
So there was a survey of over a thousand video gamers in the u s and they were
asked a bunch of questions about cryptocurrency.
The these were gamers by the way.
So 75% of them said they wished they could exchange their virtual goods for
currencies that they could buy and sell on other platforms.
So generally when gamers are earning tokens inside of a game,
they can only spend it within the game.
But what if they could spend it outside of the game?
And that is really the key for where cryptocurrency can play into video game
based assets.
Two thirds of them want more opportunities to use cryptocurrency within their
video game network.
And 55% of millennials have millennial video gamers own cryptocurrency.
So that's cool.
That's a lot.
That's more than half of millennial video game players own cryptocurrency.
So there's a huge market for this.
And why do they want this?
Well,
it turns out that it's easier to use.
There's low exchange rates and there's heightened security,
right?
Because there's a blockchain involved.
So there's some more stats,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But the point is that this is a new class of digital assets and it's all powered
by cryptocurrency.
So there was a East sports tournament recently that was held online and the,
and the prize pool was worth a hundred thousand US dollars.
This was a big deal.
So you can consider the gamers who trade in game virtual items,
also called skins in this case,
to have a similar experience to cryptocurrency traders.
They both deal in digital property,
they both face risks involved with trading online and they both have concerns
about the security of their online wallets.
Here's a picture of a popular tournament in Korea.
So the first point I want to talk about is XP coin.
So we can go to its website here,
x p coin,
that Io.
So they say it's to incentivize rewards through using this digital currency.
So I did,
I did a bit of research on XP coin and they've partnered with a bunch of people.
They partnered with global e-sports,
cooler master,
red bull and video twitch,
Zodiac Razor.
So there's a lot of companies that have partnered with this coin and that seems
to be key in this space to partner with these leading brands that can then
promote your,
your token to the gamers worldwide.
And ideally these companies have gamers that are already embedded in their
communities.
They now have the number one Overwatch team in India.
So that's top 10 in Asia,
they're developing an e sports arena in Asia with a bunch of high end PC.
So once you had this network built,
once you have this community,
then you can use the token to fund these things like a physical place.
You can use it to fund tournaments,
you can use it to fund,
you know,
different things.
And the community can even use these tokens to fund their own thing.
So you can have essentially a decentralized movement that the creator,
the token,
they just kind of set rules into the protocol and,
and let it flourish and then let the community take over from there.
But they're working on an ecommerce store as well where you can purchase all
sorts of end game assets and items.
And this network that they built consists of a bunch of roles.
So this is a very important concept when creating any kind of community.
When you have your token,
you don't just want to have an ICO and just say,
you know,
buy this coin,
et Cetera,
that's it and we're going to use it.
You want to have some kind of rule set for your community.
So it's best to think of this beforehand,
right?
So they've got these,
they have this idea of a super node and a Dev node and a sales note and a Geo
node master node.
And all of these nodes have different roles in the community.
For example,
the sales node will receive XP coin in return for selling some kind of
experience or sales related product.
The Dev node is going to be related to development.
The supernode is kind of getting money from the other nodes to maintain the
network.
Geo nodes are location based.
So as long as you have these roles and they're clear set,
people will take them up.
You've got to have a good plan in place for your token to actually take off.
You can't be in it just for the money.
There's gotta be some value that you're providing or your coin will tank and the
market will decide for you.
So what they did was they forked pure coin.
So pure coin was a fork of bitcoin that implemented proof of stake.
And this was a really good idea because proof of stake is the way to go.
It's theory is using it or they're going to start using it,
and the whole space will start moving towards proof of stake because it's more
energy efficient and it's just a better system in general for security purposes,
proof of work is being consolidated by a bunch of big GPU farms,
right?
So the idea is that proof of work prevents any kind of 51% attack because you'd
have to have a lot of computing power.
But the problem is that two thirds of the network is owned by a few entities.
So there is a centralization when it comes to big coins,
a proof of work algorithm.
So the way out of this is by using proof of stake and that's what pure coin
uses.
That's what XP coin,
you know,
they,
they forked off of it.
But what I wanted to do,
what I want to do is take,
take this opportunity,
this to segway into proof of stake and how proof of stake works,
right?
Because they're using it and it seems to be a very good protocol is getting more
and more popular.
So you might've heard a lot about Ethereum's Casper if you're,
if you're into ethereum,
the word Casper is showing up a lot in forums and you know,
slack channels and all this stuff.
But basically what Casper is,
is it's a version of proof of stake.
It's the latest version and they plan on implementing it very,
very soon.
But,
but it's,
it's a four step process,
Casper and it's,
it's the proof of stake process.
So step one is the validators steak,
a portion of their ethers.
So the validators of the network are confirming transactions,
right?
And they're getting paid in the theory.
So what they'll do is they'll stake a portion of their ethers,
like whatever x is.
So we can define that in the protocol.
So let's say I've got a hundred ethers,
I'm going to take 10 of them.
Okay.
So that's step one.
I've,
I've staked 10 ethers.
Step two is that after that they'll start validating the blocks.
That's,
that's confirming that these transactions are valid.
When they discover a block that they think can be added to the chain,
a proper valid block,
they will validate it by placing a bet on it.
Okay.
So they'll say,
okay,
this is very likely a valid block.
I'm going to bet that it is.
So if the block gets appended to the list,
to the blockchain,
then the validators will get a reward proportionate to their bets.
So the more you bet on a block,
the more a validator bets on a block,
the higher the reward is,
right?
So if the validator acts in a malicious manner and tries to do nothing at stake,
they'll immediately be reprimanded and all their steak is going to get slashed.
So that's kind of the security mechanism here,
right?
Because evaluator,
in order to say a block is valid or not has to stake some of their coins.
And if they're trying to,
if they're trying to defraud the system,
then they're their stake that they had to um,
put into this.
Essentially an escrow like service will be,
will be wiped out and then they won't get to get that money back.
So in order to vote,
you have to have stake in the network.
And if you try to do something bad,
if you try to say of transaction was valid and it's,
it wasn't,
then that state goes away.
So this is really the best pseudocode that I could find.
It's not even pseudocode,
it's just python,
but it's,
it's the ethereum Casper script.
Uh,
and what we're going to do is we're going to take a look at it.
It's about 400 lines.
So it's quite a long time.
I know.
But let's just try to understand how this works programmatically.
You are right,
we know the basic idea that we have a set of validators in the network.
They're going to put some amount of ether at stake there.
Once you vote on whether or not a block is valid.
And if they are correct,
then they earn some money.
If they're not,
if they've,
if they've tried to beef defraud the system and they're going to lose that
steak.
So that's the basic idea.
So at the start we're going to define all of these variables.
There's quite a lot of variables here.
So what in the in here we have this concept of a dynasty.
So validators are grouped into what are called dynasties and dynasties are
groups of validators.
It's just a way of segmenting up the network to improve the speed of
transactions and of voting on whether or not a transaction is valid or not.
There's a bunch of his historical check when Hashes.
So checkpoints in this case are just meant to speed up a transaction validation,
right?
Because if we have a checkpoint,
a validator doesn't have to validate every single block that came before,
right?
We can just have this checkpoint and say it's starting from here.
Start validating onward.
So it just speeds up a computation in the network.
If we keep going down,
there's quite a lot of variables,
but I think the best thing for us to do,
it's to look at the main coach is just get an idea of the programmatic
implementation of proof of stake.
So if we go down here,
we're going to see,
let's see.
Yeah,
the,
the voting process,
right?
So this is under deaf vote.
So this is the voting process right here.
So because it's in python,
it's going to be downloaded by every node in the network.
Every validator is going to be running this code.
So under the vote function we can see what does it take for validator to get to
vote.
So the vote message is going to be the vote for a validator.
And so when a validator executes the vote function,
that vote message is going to be input as the parameter to the function.
So it's going to be,
you know,
simply we can think of it as a binary.
Yes,
no,
right?
But it's a 10 24 byte message.
So it fits onto a blockchain.
It's a very thin message.
And once they voted,
then it's going to do these series of steps here to say whether or not the vote
was valid.
So the first step really is to say,
let's start a dynasty.
So let's start a dynasty.
So a dynasty consists of a set of validators right here.
And so once we have that dynasty,
we're going to say,
well,
what is the,
what is the overall vote of that dynasty?
So another reason for having a dynasty is to say,
what is the majority vote of this dynasty to speed up the voting process?
Just kind of similar to the l,
the electoral college in the,
in the United States.
It's not that every single person votes,
but it's kind of like a delegation of votes.
And then what is the larger vote of his delegation?
We send them,
we send that up to the federal level.
So it's kind of like that,
but for proof of stake voting,
who is it?
Okay.
Here's the current vote of the dynasty wardrobe in a store in current dynasty.
And once we have that,
we can record that the validator voted for this target epoch.
So they can't again.
So what happens to this record of whether or not the validator,
the record that this vote took place and then inside of the current dynasty will
increment all of those variables that we initialize earlier to say,
well the validator index,
he voted,
let's add one to it and then do it for the next validator.
So there's some count of the number of validators in the network and now that
this validators voted increment the validator index to the next one.
So we can say,
okay,
this new identity is going to be the next validator.
So this is really the,
the validation part right here.
So once the validators voted,
if enough votes with the same source epoch and Hash are made,
then the hash value is justified.
That means that if enough validators that have put stake into the system have
voted and that and those votes were indeed valid,
then and only then can that vote be added or that block be added to the
blockchain.
Right?
Because it is a valid vote.
And that's essentially what this last part does.
But yeah,
there's,
there's quite a bit to proof of stake.
But that's the general idea.
And I just want it to go into that for a second.
But let's keep going here because we have quite a bit more to cover.
So wax wax is another cryptocurrency in this space.
So these are essentially utility tokens that allow for virtual goods to easily
be tokenized that and exchanged for cryptocurrency.
So any kind of endgame asset,
whether that's,
you know,
looking at the amount of shields that you got in some,
medieval game or some kind of,
you know,
map that you bought or some skin for some new kind of you weapon in some kind of
counter strike like game,
anything like that,
you can tokenize that and then sell it using this cryptocurrency.
And you can link all of those in game assets to this cryptocurrency.
So there are timestamped on the blockchain and then you can have the name of it
as well embedded in that,
uh,
25 character hash.
So it's provable.
That's the point.
So the,
the wax platform,
you know,
they have,
they have a lot going for them.
But what I find really interesting is how they raised their token sale.
So if we look at their token sale,
they raised quite a lot.
They,
they raised quite a lot of money.
But the really interesting bit is that if we look at their,
uh,
token contract,
it's essentially just a fork of the Zeplin solidity standard token contract.
So Zeplin basically makes making Erc 20 tokens very,
very easy.
And if you look at this code,
it's only 89 lines of code.
And what they did was they just forked it and they just added their own,
uh,
customized parameters to the code.
So if we look in here,
we say,
okay,
the constant Amy,
it's a wax token,
here's a symbol,
here's how many decimal points.
So eight decimal points,
and here's the initial supply.
And they used,
you know,
scientific notation to say,
this is there.
There are quite a lot of tokens.
So if we look in all of these functions here,
that's just it.
It's just transfer.
It's transfer from address,
approve,
increase approval.
Why not paused,
decrease approval.
There's only seven functions in this code and they raised at least 50 million
USD.
It's quite a lot of money,
but it's just the power of ics,
of tokens,
of exchanges.
There's,
there's quite a lot and you know,
a lot of it isn't even justified.
It's just people don't even understand what they're investing in and they just
see something and they're like,
okay,
I need to pour a lot of money into this because it seems like it's good,
but a lot of times it's really just smoke and mirrors.
So we have to be very careful into what we invest in.
And the best way to do that is not,
is not to look at landing pages,
it's not to look at,
uh,
the hype around something.
It's to look at the code.
If you can do that,
if you can understand the code behind some protocol,
then you're set then and only then should you really invest a lot of money
because the code is really what matters,
right?
That's,
that's the real,
that's the real value that some unique token provides,
right?
If you have a bunch of coins for some space,
whether that's e sports or this or that,
and there's 20 different players in the field,
who is gonna win,
right?
Who's going to be the token that the most people adopt?
It's going to be a token that has the most value,
right?
And if all of them are just forks of the same token,
who's going to win?
It's the one that provides that unique code base and that unique code base
that's not just unique,
but it provides real value.
And the best way to do that is to look at the code.
So this is just kind of uh,
an analysis,
an example of how you should be analyzing all of these tokens in the space.
Let's keep going.
So unocoin it's another one.
Unicorn bet.
Play Watch,
same exact idea.
It's for in game assets,
for bedding on the ethereum blockchain.
Interestingly,
Mark Cuban invested in this,
so they've got $100 million token sale.
Quite a lot of hype behind this one.
But if we look in their token distribution contract,
we'll see again,
same thing.
Zeplin template,
right?
What's the difference between Unicorn and a wax?
Nothing really programmatically.
It's the same exact contract.
They've got an ERC 20 they've got a different landing page,
they've skinnded,
they've wrapped it differently.
But under the hood,
it's the same exact template.
They have a different number of coins.
They have this a presale token allocation cap.
We have a post sale token allocation cap,
and they have a few more variables.
But essentially it's the same thing.
So it's really important to be able to look at these and say,
you know what,
how good something is and how good it's not.
So let's go to the last one.
So this one is really interesting.
So it's called Chimera,
and they say that this is the ultimate blockchain game development platform.
But crucially they don't have any code because they just don't have any code.
It's just a landing page.
But they've,
they've,
they're raising quite a lot of money from just a landing page.
Right.
That's what I look for first for first is do they have code?
Yes.
No,
the answer,
no,
I'm just,
I'm just going to keep walking.
Right.
So that's something you should do as well anyway,
so they want,
so I'm not saying that there are fraudulent,
I'm just saying that this is something that helps investors.
If you want people to invest,
if you want more hype,
have your code base available for people to view.
So these are,
so the idea is that you can take a video game,
any kind of game and decentralize it on the blockchain.
What do I mean?
So if right now games are hosted on giant servers,
world of Warcraft for example,
Blizzard owns the server.
So you're connecting to blizzard.
It blizzard decides to stop,
you know,
maintaining world of Warcraft,
then everybody doesn't get to play anymore.
But in,
in a decentralized space,
there are multiple servers holding this game and people can interact with each
other in a pure to pure way.
There's no way to shut the game down.
Also,
if you're an indie game developer,
then the costs,
the costs of the infrastructure to get your game out there in front of many,
many people,
it's a lot.
So you might be thinking,
how are they putting an entire game on the blockchain,
right?
Games or multiple gigabytes of data.
They're not.
And if you have any kind of game that's related to the blockchain,
you shouldn't put it on the blockchain.
Just try,
it's not gonna work.
It's too big.
Right?
Blockchains are very,
very thin clients.
And,
and to have every node in a network download the game,
it's preposterous.
It's not going to work.
What should you do instead?
Well,
you should use what's called the distributed hash table to store the data.
What the blockchain is for is for application level constructs.
So usernames,
uh,
tweets,
anything that the network has to agree upon.
Game states,
that's what you would use a blockchain for.
Application level constructs go on the blockchain.
The data itself is stored in a distributed hash table like IPFS.
So that's how they should do it.
I Dunno how exactly they're doing it.
They weren't very specific,
but they have this idea of game channels.
So game channels are what are called off chain transactions.
So in the bitcoin network there's this concept of a lightening network.
And the lightening network says,
W I'm a node,
you're node.
Let me transfer you some value without going on the bitcoin blockchain.
So which is the peer to peer note what?
What is,
what's going on?
The blockchain is a record of that transaction,
but it's a very thin record.
It's not a huge record like an unnormal blockchain transaction takes a lot of
time right there.
There's a lot of time involved in the transaction and at least 10 minutes at
this point,
but that's too long.
And so the reason they call it a lightening network is because it's very fast
because it avoids using a blockchain.
It's a direct peer to peer transfer without it being on the chain.
So they're using this concept to store game states very fast because game states
need to be fast in terms of the game,
right?
If you're in position,
hey,
you need to go to position B,
the network needs to agree that you moved,
but you need to do this in a fast way.
Game channels are the way to go.
But if we look at this code here,
let's,
let's look at some code.
So even though they don't have any code available,
I did find some game contract code.
So this is a protocol called Izea x and it's a game protocol that uses smart
contracts to agree on application level constructs.
So they have fun,
they have four different um,
smart contracts,
which is very interesting and I think this is a good way to do things.
They have one which is called game.
And that's defining the base abstract concept of your game.
You have token game,
which defines the Games token rev share game.
And so this is an example of how to share that value between players and then
game controller.
So this is which control.
So this controls which token holder has what and to what extent they can
participate in the game.
And they have contracts for all of this and solidity.
But interestingly,
the game contract is probably the one that we should be looking at right now.
So up here they have some rules of the game,
like two roles,
essentially the game issue or places,
the number of prizes into the,
into the contract and the seed to calculate those hashes.
They're unknown.
And kept in secret.
So once players play the game,
the issue,
or may give a secret seed to the winter,
the winter claims the prize and gets a reward.
So this is an example of using an application level construct for something
that's essentially a massively online multiplayer game,
right?
Keep the thin stuff in the smart contracts,
the big stuff in the distributed hash table,
and we're good to go.
Anyway,
I hope you found this video useful and please subscribe for more programming
videos.
For now.
I've got to visit decentral land,
so thanks for watching.